una fiesta falsa interrumpida por la
policía oficiales a caballo dispersaron
la multitud con cañones de agua y gas
lacrimógeno enfriando los ánimos de los
juerguistas en bruselas son jóvenes que
dicen estar cansados de las
restricciones de la pandemia 7 para la
youtube
protestar ni nada decir que tenemos el
derecho de estar aquí en una zona
pública
nos imponen demasiadas normas nos privan
de nuestra libertad aunque somos
conscientes del problema no negamos el
cob y vamos con cuidado pero necesitamos
vivir un poco este falso festival era
una broma en las redes sociales en el
cartel
calvin harris el reencuentro de daft
punk y varios dj más a pesar de las
advertencias de las autoridades unas
2000 personas se reunieron y la fiesta
se descontroló
bélgica ha tomado estrictas medidas para
frenar las infecciones de kobe 19 en el
país
las fronteras siguen cerradas las
escuelas también y las reuniones
limitadas a cuatro personas
el país cuenta 23.000 muertes por kobe
19 y las autoridades recuerdan que los
contagios deben prevenirse para que las
ucis no colapsen
[Aplausos]